with inflation hovering around its
highest rate in 40 years the federal
reserve is expected to raise interest
rates several times in 2022
this is fed chairman jerome powell on
what will be needed to ensure a long
economic expansion that's going to
require
the fed to tighten interest rate policy
and do our part
in getting inflation back down to our
two percent goal the way the central
bank does this is by changing the
federal funds rate its main tool for
managing the economy you can see on this
chart that the rate was lowered to
nearly zero percent in 2020 to boost the
economy at the beginning of the pandemic
there is an important job for us
to move away from these very highly
stimulative monetary policy settings
adjustments to the federal funds rate
influence a range of borrowing costs
from how much you own your credit card
to mortgage rates they also shape
broader decisions made by companies like
how many people to hire or whether to
raise prices
here's how the federal funds rate works
and how just one rate can guide the
entire economy
[Music]
the fed meets every six or so weeks and
they're looking at a range of economic
data at those meetings but they have two
main goals one is to ensure stable
prices and low inflation and the other
is to make sure that the layer market is
strong nick timaros covers how the fed
guides the economy through crises he
says he can think of the economy as a
car and the fed as the driver they want
to make sure that the economy's not
growing too slow and when it is they'll
push on the gas but they also want to
make sure that it's not going too fast
and so they'll slow the economy down by
pressing on the break this is where the
federal funds rate comes in when you
hear on the news about the fed raising
interest rates or cutting interest rates
what they're actually deciding to do is
to raise or to lower the federal funds
rate this is the interest rate that
banks charge each other to borrow money
overnight
but there's a catch the federal funds
rate isn't directly set by the federal
reserve so in order to influence it the
fed uses a couple of other tools to set
a target range these tools are rates
that the fed controls in its role as a
bank for banks here's the target range
that was in place during 2021. the
federal reserve sets an upper limit and
a lower limit with the goal of keeping
the effective federal funds rate
somewhere in between the upper limit is
determined by interest on reserve
balances this is the rate of interest a
bank gets on deposits known as reserves
that it keeps at the federal reserve the
lower limit is determined by overnight
reverse repurchases these are securities
like treasury bills but the federal
reserve lends to banks usually for a day
while paying interest
on this chart you can see where the fed
has set the target range between the two
yellow lines the blue line which is the
effective federal funds rate set by
banks sits between the upper and lower
limits as the target range changes the
effective rate goes up or down with it
so far they've had very successful
control over guiding the federal funds
rate and guiding
all short-term money market rates to
where they generally are trying to move
them
the fed makes these adjustments in
fairly small increments its rate
increases for 2022 are expected to only
change by about a quarter to a half of a
point at a time
so how can these tiny adjustments for
banks help cool down the entire economy
it all has to do with how those rates
ripple through the system as banks are
charged more to borrow they'll in turn
charge their customers more affecting
the cost of existing loans and demand
for new borrowing
the goal of raising these rates is to
drive down demand inflation results when
supply and demand are out of whack the
fed can't do anything to increase the
supply of oil or to increase the number
of houses for sale the supply side is
something out of their reach but they
can bring supply into demands by
reducing demand here's how interest
rates can influence demand and inflation
when rates are low more people and
businesses are likely to take out loans
higher demand for goods and services as
well as lower rates allows employers to
open more positions to meet demand and
raise wages to appeal to potential
employees consumers then turn around and
spend those wages on goods and services
which in turn can lead to more jobs and
higher prices the opposite happens when
rates are higher fewer people and
businesses take out loans job growth
slows and spending decreases
higher interest rates may also make it
more appealing to save inflation slows
as supply and demand balance out while
interest rates can be effective in
bringing inflation down a rate hike
could take some time to make an impact
think about your own life as you go
through making different decisions about
whether to buy a house and how big of a
house to buy it may take a while for
this to to ripple through the housing
market for example but in 6 or 12 months
we could begin to see
you know less demand if interest rates
are high enough to slow interested
consumers but while inflation may take
time to come down consumers and
businesses will likely feel the impact
of higher interest rates on loans
mortgages and credit cards right away
[Music]